planning de conférences et d'ateliers en
tous genres sit in et banderoles bien
accroché les étudiants de l'école
agroparistech sont organisés depuis le
15 mars
ils bloquent l'entrée de leur
établissement pour protester contre la
vente au travers d'un appel d'offres du
centre de grignon ou une partie de
l'école est installé depuis 1826 on veut
que ce site des rares est public tout
simplement parce que ce site est chargé
d'un patrimoine matériel et immatériel
et naturel qui selon nous sont
indispensables dans le cadre des
transitions futur ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose qu'on demande
c'est de pouvoir discuter du coup les
termes du cahier des charges de la vente
cette vente fait suite au déménagement
voter en 2015 des étudiants de première
année sur le plateau de saclay pour
financer ce déménagement l'école devant
le centre historique de grignan quatre
offres ont donc été déposés dont des
sociétés de construction et promoteurs
immobiliers ce qui ne plaît pas aux
étudiants le seul candidat qui a été
vraiment transparent il se trouve que
c'est justement ce projet-là de la
communauté commune avec l'union 2026 qui
sont venus nous expliquer leur projet
qu'ils sont a priori d'accord pour nous
inclure aussi dans la construction de
leur projet mais on n'a aucune
information sur les autres les étudiants
sont soutenus par une partie des
professeurs et chercheurs
d'agroparistech et de l'inra qui se
reconnaissent dans leur mobilisation
on peut pas continuer à faire comme si
nous n'existions pas pour cette vente
donc je rejoins complètement là la
demande qu'ont fait les étudiants
récemment ils ont trouvé une des
modalités d'action pour le moment
totalement non violente et de façon
assez exceptionnelle je dois le dire
ce vendredi 26 mars est la date butoir
pour que l'état suspende annuler
confirme l'appel d'offres les étudiants
demandent la mise en pause pour
rediscuter les termes ils l'ont fait
savoir à un conseil du ministre julien
de normandie ancien élève
d'agroparistech et ils le feront à
nouveau savoir en manifestant ce
vendredi à 14h de son côté la direction
n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer